so this red curve is the graph of f of x
and this blue curve is the graph of g of
x and i want to try to express g of x in
terms of f of x
and so let's see how they're related so
we pick any x and we could start right
here at the vertex of f of x and we see
that at least at that point g of x is
exactly one higher than that
so g of 2
i could write this down
g of 2
g of 2 is equal to is equal to f of 2
f of 2 plus 1
plus 1. let's see if that's true for any
x so then we can just sample over here
well let's see g of let's see f of 4 is
right over here g of 4 is 1 more than
that
f of f of 6 is right here
g of 6 is one more than that so it looks
like if we pick any point over here even
though there's a little bit of an
optical illusion it looks like they get
closer together they do if you look try
to find the closest distance between the
two but if you look at vertical distance
you see that it stays a constant it
stays a constant one so we can actually
generalize this this is true for any x
g of x
is equal to f of x
plus one
let's do a few more examples of this so
right over here here is f of x in red
again and here is g of x
and so let's say we picked x equals
negative 4 this is f of negative 4 and
we say we see g of negative 4 is 2 less
than that
and we see whatever f of x is g of x no
matter where we no matter what x we pick
g of x seems to be exactly two less
g of x is exactly exactly
two less
so in this case very similar to the
other one g of x is going to be equal to
f of x but instead of adding we're going
to subtract 2 from f of x f of x
minus 2. let's do a few more examples
so here we have f of x in red again i'll
relabel it f of x
and here is g of x here is g of x
so let's think about it a little bit
let's pick a let's pick an arbitrary
point here let's say we have in red here
this is
this point right over there is the value
of f of three
so that or f of negative three i should
say this is negative three this is the
point negative three f of three so
negative three
f of three
now g hits that same value when x is
equal to negative one
when x is equal to
negative one so let's think about this g
g of negative one is equal to
f of negative three
is equal to f of negative three and we
could do that with a bunch of points we
could see
that
g of
g of 0
g of 0 which is right there let me do in
the color you can see g of 0 is
equivalent
is equivalent to f of negative 2. so let
me write that down
g
of 0
is equal to
f of negative 2.
we could keep doing that we could say g
of 1
g of 1
g of 1 which is right over here this is
1. g of 1 is equal to f of negative 1.
g
of 1
is equal to
f of
negative 1. so i think you see the
pattern here
g of whatever is equal to
f of is equal to the function evaluated
at two less than whatever is here so we
could say
we could say that g of x is equal to
f of
what's going to be 2 less than x so f of
x
minus 2. so this is the relationship g
of x is equal to f of x minus 2. it's
important to realize here when i did f
of x minus 2 here and remember i'm
taking the function is being evaluated
this
this is the input x minus 2 is the input
when i subtract the 2 this is shifting
the function to the right which is a
little bit counter-intuitive unless you
go through this exercise right over here
so g of x is equal to f of x minus 2. if
it was f of x plus 2 we would have
actually shifted f to the left
now let's think about this one this one
is seems kind of wacky
so first of all g of x it's it it almost
looks like a mirror image but it looks
like it's been flattened out
so let's think of it this way
let's take the mirror image of what g of
x is so i'm gonna try my best to take
the mirror image of it so let's see it
gets to about two there then it gets
pretty close to one right over there and
then it gets about right over there so
if i were to take its mirror image it
looks something
it looks something like this it's mirror
image if i were to reflect it across the
across the x-axis
it looks something like this
so this right over here
this right over here we would call so if
this is negative if this is g of x if
this is g of x when we flip it that way
this is the negative g of x
negative g of x when x equals 4
g of x looks like it's i don't know
about negative three and a half you take
the negative of that you get positive i
guess it should be closer to you get
positive three and a half if you take
the exact mirror image so that's
negative g of x but that still doesn't
get us there it looks like we actually
have to triple this value for any point
and you see it here this this gets to
two but we need to get to six this gets
to one but we need to get to three so it
looks like this red graph right over
here is three times this graph so this
is
three times negative g of x
which is equal to
negative
three
g of x
so here we have f of x
is equal to negative 3 times g of x
and if we wanted to solve for g of x
write g of x in terms of f of x we would
write
dividing both sides by negative 3
g of x is equal to negative one-third f
of x
negative one-third
f of x